all right this is the less economic
policy in two sentences number one
americans should spend a lot less
number two
the government should spend a lot more
you got it
and democrats by the way are about to
pop open the champagne on capitol hill
why because they're closer to spending
trillions of dollars we don't have on
stuff we don't need
now as predicted joe manchin seems
poised to betray the people of west
virginia and agree to this massive bill
and biden wants these gargantuan
spending packages why because he wants
him for his big trip to glasgow for
climate change
all so he can say see guys we're
behaving over there in the united states
we're serious about changing our ways
look we're creating a new expanded
welfare state and more giveaways to
cronies who offer green solutions
it's so pathetic and so predictable
meanwhile as we unilaterally disarm on
oil and gas germany is building coal
plants of course they are and of course
china never stopped
belton road baby all the way it's all
that matters to china global domination
of every industry
and the eu in china loves seeing america
prostrate herself on the world stage
because with biden in charge
they'll almost always get their way
and somehow back at home
biden's team thinks that they're going
to get their way with the voters by
stoking inflation with all this spending
they think biden's record low approval
numbers will be revived when people's
paychecks are ravaged by inflation
it seems the only argument for the left
is you know for democrats at this point
is that the same one that jimmy carter
tried to resounding defeat
people you consume too much
many of us now
tend to worship
self-indulgence and consumption but
we've discovered
that owning things and consuming things
does not satisfy
our longing for meaning
piling up material goods
cannot fill the emptiness of lives
which have no confidence or purpose
oh depressing
now the press knows that as long as the
democrats stay in power americans are
going to see their standard of living
decline
so all they can do now is
try to persuade us
to accept
that decline
and to that end a lefty writer over at
slate named kevin matson
actually pines for the days of jimmy
carter
and he wishes that biden could give a
speech urging americans to do with less
something like
we're used to pushing a button and
getting a product delivered
that might have been a necessity at the
height of the pandemic but now it's
indefensible that is if we care about
carbon footprints climate change
please
i'm begging him biden should give his
own malay speech just like that please
do it
now all the usual suspects are picking
up on this theme of lowering
expectations over at nbc
they want americans to stop using
automobiles check out this title
americans are in total collective denial
about how lethal our car dependency is
we have to stop normalizing the
suffering caused by cars
is it just me or is this all starting to
sound like the babylon bee
now the point is
it's really hard to convince americans
to shrink their ambitions
pursuing and achieving and yes
purchasing according to our own free
will
it's ingrained into americans dna that's
why
biden though is using a rhetorical
sleight of hand
with his lame build back better to sell
all this nonsense
well let me tell you there's just
nothing better about it
and there's nothing original about it
either
joe's speechwriters stole the theme from
the one world crowd
we owe it to future generations
to build back better including a fairer
greener and more resilient global
economy build back much better more
resilient economies and societies
looking ahead we need to build back
better
i don't know why i find this hilarious
mine's always plagiarizing
of course when china hears this clap
trap they see a chance
to degrade the power of the u.s and the
power of the nation-state standing up
totalitarianism
so china then gets to write the rules of
the road while using all the sappy
greniac lingo
the earth is our one and only home
to scale up efforts to address climate
change
and promote sustainable development
global response
and global cooperation
i mean this is just all music to the
ears of the world economic forum which
has always seen the us
as an impediment to globalism
remember back in the 2016 uh time frame
during the campaign
the wef painted the picture of their
utopia in the not so distant future
welcome to the year 2030 welcome to my
city or should i say our city
i don't own anything i don't own a car i
don't own a house i don't own any
appliances or any clothes
it might seem odd to you but it makes
perfect sense for us in this city
and what were they saying about rent at
the world economic forum nah
they envisioned it's all free because
it's communal
in our city we don't pay any rent
because someone else is using our free
space whenever we do not need it
my living room is used for business
meetings when i'm not there oh that
sounds fun
and by the way the global elite don't
want you worrying about that whole
privacy thing anymore either once in a
while i get annoyed about the fact that
i have no real privacy
know where i can i go and not be
registered
i know that somewhere everything i do
think and dream of is recorded i just
hope that nobody will use it against me
all in all
it's a good life
that's not made up that's real doesn't
it sound like a young ccp
kind of
pamphlet and four years later
the word collective gets used more
national sovereignty is a quaint
outdated idea for the global
billionaires
2021 will be the critical year to
re-establish trust
in our ability
to shape our common future in collective
and constructive ways the recovery
cannot be a mere
the reconstruction must be a
transformation every country city
financial institution and company
needs to adopt credible plans for
transition to net zero emissions by 2050
you can be sure that klaus schwab will
not suffer under this new regime
if anything he and the rest of the
global billionaires will only get richer
but working-class americans will feel
the pain and they're forced to sacrifice
and they'll be forced to tailor their
dreams to this new global normal
by the way it's a new normal where
america is just another country in a
global league of nations no better and
no worse
now i remember reagan's answer to this
type of defeatist approach that was sold
by jimmy carter when reagan spoke at the
1980 gop convention
they tell us they've done the most that
could humanly be done
they say that the united states has had
its day in the sun
that our nation has passed its zenith
they expect you to tell your children
that the american people no longer have
the will to cope with their problems
that the future will be one of sacrifice
and few opportunities
my fellow citizens i utterly reject that
view the american people the most
generous on earth who created the
highest standard of living
are not going to accept the notion that
we can only make a better world for
others by moving backward ourselves
the people we ran into in mississippi
seemed to carry that same optimistic
spirit forward
you know mississippi it's a state that
of course has its problems but right now
its economy is booming
and its unemployment rate is nearly half
that of new york city
the people of mississippi we ran into
are not interested in settling for less
democrats and some in the media are
saying it's time for you as an american
to scale back your expectations do
make do with less
is that acceptable to you
you should not change your lifestyle
absolutely not you should do what you
want how you want we're the country that
leads the free world
and uh to have jennifer saki out there
saying stuff like oh we're having a
crisis about treadmill is ridiculous and
it's insulting i've been working since
i'm 16 years old and i'm going to
continue to work
and provide for my family and do what we
want to do
more americans are seeing it biden and
the democrats offer an ideology of
despair and decline
meanwhile our populist movement teaches
that through hard work and innovation
and by staying true to our traditions
americans of all races
can build a better life for themselves
and their families
that's the american dream
which biden and his global fraud friends
must never be allowed to steal from us
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else